we're talking super bowl sunday with
dynamic duo carrie champion of jamal
hill yes
hi
um all right guys rossi what's next all
right well this is the first time in
almost 20 years that the super bowl has
not been held on the first sunday of the
month and the independent reports not
everybody is happy with the new date
because it crashes right into
valentine's day weekend right and tick
tock wants to know who is responsible
for this and they think definitely
someone
is single who is this somebody that does
not have
a valentine to spend you and me carry
correct i i didn't do the math really
that it's sunday the 13th is super bowl
next day is valentine's day people are
probably going to be hungover not their
best version of themselves for
valentine's day and yet i feel like i've
been invited um for the first time in
what seems like years
because it is i've been invited to some
valentine's day parties that are
happening on saturday night so i feel
like it's like halloween people are
getting their valentine's day on over
the weekend valentine's day party so i'm
like what are people complaining about
you got saturday nights sunday football
and monday valentine's day what is the
problem
but carrie jamel thoughts
i'm over valentine's day and i just feel
like here's here comes grumpy carrie i
feel like everyone uh it's a made up
holiday especially when you're single
and for single people it really is just
another reminder if you're not in a good
space that you ain't got no man or no
woman so therefore i'm all about the
football unlike my my bestie jamelle
here who's like i'm taking my husband
we're in line love
that's cute
that's good canal thoughts feelings
valentine's day super bowl what's it all
about
so
this to me is the perfect time to
wage my campaign
and i always feel like any politician
that's running for office if you want to
unite the entire country we need to push
for the day after super bowl to be a
national holiday that everybody
because if that were the case then it
would allow us to recalibrate and
perhaps celebrate valentine's day if you
choose to agree you got my vote i also
think i think you could sort of make
this weekend part of the valentine's day
thing so it's not just one day to
celebrate maybe you could score a
touchdown all weekend long if you know
what i mean
i mean there's you could score
score score
all right well next up we have got a
heart warmer about the bengals um there
is a die hard fan his name is james
lipscomb he's 86 years old and he has
been a fan for over 50 years he was at
the very first bengal game ever wow in
1968
and now he just went virtual for his
reaction when they beat the chiefs to
make it to the super bowl watch this
how happy are you dad
oh my
and now people report
that thanks to a gofundme campaign
started in his family
james aka
the cincinnati grandpa is headed to the
super bowl
[Applause]
and that's the kind of rallying i love
to see i mean that is just the most
heartwarming story thank you people for
bringing that to people's
attention and now he and his whole
family are going to go they raised like
forty thousand dollars they're gonna get
him tickets a hotel room great seats
come on this is this is
this gets me you know well carrie and
jamelle i just love getting to do this
with you you truly are authorities
you're incredible people
check out their podcast naked with terry
champion and jamel is unbothered and see
them together on cnn plus the show speak
easy
[Music]